hi everyone so let's get straight to the
point I'll be sharing with you three
nutritional tips for you to lose weight
without dieting I mean I do not believe
in diets don't get me wrong they work
but they only work usually for you know
a set period of time when you go on a
diet what tends to happen is that you
know for example if you were to go on a
liquid diet yes you will lose weight but
what you're losing is not fat all you're
losing is just water and muscle mass and
the elephant diet will you be able to
maintain a liquid diet for the rest of
your life the answer is no and it's not
good for you as well so today I'll be
speaking about you know ways to eat
right everybody knows how to eat healthy
when we talk about healthy eating the
first thing that comes to your mind is
you know it lean meats you know have
lots of salads you know make sure your
plate is full of green salads
you know brilliant protein but what
about eating right because eating ripe
is a key to losing weight so three tips
I would like you to follow in order to
lose weight without dieting our tip
number one your Mill intervals alright
tip number two Nutrition ratio per meal
and tip number three calories per meal
let's go into you know each tips in more
details the key to remember is that we
want our blood sugar level to be
stabilized when our blood sugar is
stabilized what happens is that our body
were stuck in a breaking down fat and
stop burning fats and we won't be
craving you know sugary food at the same
time so let's go through each of the
points in details point number one mill
intervals always remember that the first
meal which is your breakfast should be
consumed within the first hour of you
waking up breakfast means break fast so
it should be consumed within the first
hour of you making up will have an X
that you should continue eating for
every three to four hours yes you're
probably right you need to eat
frequently so every three to four hours
you should have something to eat so that
should be about five to six meals a day
what you want to be doing is to eat
small portions but frequently to
stabilize your blood sugar level and the
last meal of the day
should we consume one hour before
bedtime so yes you can eat you know near
to your bedtime I just make sure that
it's one hour before bedtime and that
you're only eating protein and fat and
not carbohydrate the key to remember is
that if you're very hungry at Meal Time
that means you've waited too long to eat
if you don't feel hungry at mealtime
that means you've consumed too much you
know in your previous meal so you should
always feel right to eat after three to
four hours so remember to eat every
three to four hours if you're not
feeling hungry after four hours eat half
the meal that you know you're supposed
to eat and if you're not hungry after
you know the next four hours it quarter
than milk but the key is you need to eat
in order to stabilize your blood sugar
level and also another important point
to remember is that you know meals and
snacks are the same so basically what
this means is that you can have your
breakfast during lunch time you can feel
lunch meal during breakfast time you
know you can mix them on kind of your
dinner during lunch time it doesn't
matter
there's no such thing as luck there's no
such thing like you know I need to have
this for breakfast that for lunch no as
long as you're eating you know three to
four every three to four hours and
eating in the right portion it doesn't
matter when you eat one meal all right
so the second point is nutrients ratio
per meal what this means is that in
every meal you should be consuming your
protein your cups and your fat protein
equals your lean meat fish tofu eggs
whereas carbohydrates equals you know
not just rice not just bread but also
all your vegetables you know I know
there are diets out there saying that
you should cut the carbs but know if you
eat two little cups what happens is that
your body would start storing fat and
your body will stop burning fat and we
don't want that by the same time if eat
too much cups your body would start too
much
at the same time and also reduce her
energy level so the key is to remember
to either write nutrient ratios per mil
so what is the right neutral ratio per
mil protein and carbs should be eaten at
almost the same ratio whereas fat should
always be at the lowest amount so let's
say let's put protein carbs and fat at
100% that should only be consumed about
20 percent and that is literally a
teaspoon of olive oil or you know a
teaspoon of butter or peanut butter
things like that it's in minimum portion
whereas protein and carb should be about
40 and 40 percent each or you can have
more protein for a 5 percent and 35
percent of car by balancing out your
neutral ratio your body is getting the
essential nutrient that your body needs
and therefore you maximize fat burning
and the third point is everybody knows
this calories per meal so if you're
eating so frequently you should not be
consume a lot of calories per meal for
women I would suggest that you consume
about 250 to 350 calories whereas for
men you can consume about 400 to 450
calories per meal well it also depends
on your activity level if you're a very
active person whether being a male or
female then obviously you need to
consume more calories but you know if
you're doing a lot of office work and
you're not moving much at all try to
stick to the guideline of 250 to 350
calories for women and 400 to 450
calories for men per meal so that
includes your protein your cards and
your fats too many calories consumed
Adam Adam Ellie increases fat storage
and reduces your appetite on the next
meal and 2-liter calories consumed at a
meal with drug a blood sugar level
therefore you will start craving you
know sugary stuff and whenever you see
something that it's sweet what you want
me to do you would just grab it and eat
it without even thinking so how do we
know we're consuming the right calories
the key is to remember that you should
satisfied after each meal so if you're
feeling too full after a meal that's
telling me that you eating too much if
you're still feeling hungry after an
hour that's telling me that you're
eating too little so the key is to just
feel satisfied and not over indulging
those are the three main points to
remember and practice in order to lose
weight without dieting and if you can
incorporate this to your lifestyle what
you're doing is that you will not only
be able to lose weight but to maintain
your weight for the rest of your life
and that's what we want and you know
most diets you can't do that through
most diets because they are only
temporary so remember that nutrition
should be part of your lifestyle and
that you should have fun and enjoy it 3
tips to remember first one mill
intervals second one nutria ratio per
meal and the last one calories per meal
and if you can follow this eat
frequently don't nobody go hungry
neither should you overindulge I can
assure you that you will start seeing
results you know by losing weight and
see and feeling healthier and fitter and
if there are anything that is unclear
anything that you want more elaboration
on please leave your comments and our
strive to answer them
[Music]